welcome to this video playing the
national master bows at La Marque to
trail from Belgium and got a philly dorm
neo Philidor okay let's just play em
play the main line I think this is the
main line one hundred percent sure about
age 30 kh3 is maybe not great as we
experience right now rookie oneness what
they play and now I know why hmm okay
yeah well I need to take
Bishop d3 at evening as worse for me
takes on fri night f6 very embarrassing
okay we are probably I need to play
something like this which is obviously
nothing yeah okay at least I'm not worse
I hope okay there should be six this is
a bit surprising maybe I can you can
just play Queenie 70 Queen a drive is
not really am helping be sure that form
he might even click with f6f for
looks terribly anti positional okay I
don't I didn't really see a good
solution here Bishop f4 I thought queen
it's a queen f6 Bishop f4 Queen f6 and
Queen h5 he just goes Queenie 7 and what
exactly have I accomplished okay here i
can wait a moment wait wait wait I don't
necessarily need to take on f3 now I can
think about other moves could take at
Queen f3 I can take one of seven is this
an idea okay I'm so much behind on the
clock already for nothing let's try to
speed up a bit I just want to take care
take then on f3 with the Queen should be
at least about equal this position I
don't really see any problem at least
maybe I even have something on their
farm
yeah we can try to play move like f to
check but I just take it but uh huh
guess I didn't really consider
interesting what makes make some sense
no no doubt but yeah look at seven
something like that does this really a
move hmm Jeff King takes this video
hoodia shame cannot do that that f6
check however could be a move yeah he
just takes it it doesn't help okay but
Queen h5 he can just take him really as
floodwaters stupid game okay what I
that's more like stupid play by me the
game is not to be blamed stupidest the
player usually okay what am i doing just
don't like him let's see how much
material am i down it's a doll porn okay
I'd felt was it fell to us okay but he
can
probably just take e5 you know simply
and good yeah you can just take h3
unfortunately maybe two maybe it's this
one look to g3 of course objectively and
I'm just lost but there it can always
try to to to catch people the shop can
loopy aid unfortunately
I can play this one on rook e8 high of
root g 7 ok yeah this is a big check
yeah he has many ways to win I guess who
creates the Luke Chisum about the only
idea and i also have a hard time to even
get the g-tube on it's it's really an
it's really tough there's always defying
is taking some time it feels like any
move should win but maybe this is not
the case just retreats interesting
push-up h6 group check i can take the
rook is immediately hanging so this rook
check f1 doesn't really help and if you
place rook f7 i'm going to take on g7
with quite some simplifications i mean i
get i get some material lack rook takes
rook takes Queen takes Queen take c6
check it's really okay giving me much
more Hope than I expected and deserve
after clam what I played in this game
check my queen g70 can pick good play
and now Queen a 5k I'm not quite sure
why just he can simply try to win inking
opponent game all the time tires line
doesn't do it now is doing it and maybe
it is not so easily winning know that
I'll think of it because of my Good King
position check
threatening Queen g5 check check wall
check
amazingly i'm winning check check check
check Wow hahaha this was a really
really bad I guess this was probably
wasn't it wasn't mad or anything somehow
somehow I didn't he didn't finish me off
I don't know why it felt completely
completely lost and here I'm having
slide helps I mean where the company is
just minus 1 and minus 1 is really a
really great Fred comparison it still
wants to check on f1 and then retreat to
f7 for whatever reason and this is this
is a draw yeah by perpetual check but he
constantly refuses here Queen g6 and so
on this all should be good friend
because of the of the the pass out but
yeah again Queen f5 and in this case I'm
not sure after the Queen trade I've got
such an active King it's probably ok ok
until I'm already better ok ok I'm
winning with its really really amazing
yeah you're still you should still try
to fight the the whole whole problem
started with H 3 which is really rubbish
and just just bad I mean I didn't really
know what the motif of course I know the
the general idea but not that is working
in the philly door I I must play
p 1 him just rupee one and there's no
such thing and after that already and
this is a special this is in particular
particularly embarrassing you need to
play a rubbish move like cookie Bonnie
and give up you're born Bishop p.m. yeah
and i was already already struggling i
should just play a normal move here at
four yeah and this is not working simply
simply a bad idea Knight f3 is just the
normal position probably not even a bad
one with the bishop pointing here you
shouldn't take I guess just just Knight
f6 okay thanks for watching